oui à l'une des principales
préoccupations des américains durant
cette campagne c'est la question de la
santé
avec la crise économique beaucoup ont
perdu leur emploi ne peuvent donc pas
payées d'assurance maladie or barack
obama a promis une grande réforme du
système de santé voyez le reportage de
caroline since et d'eric jamais aucune
affiche électorale dans les rudes
indianapolis
pourtant la campagne est dans tous les
esprits les américains éliront le
candidat qui répondra le mieux à leurs
inquiétudes économiques se payer une
assurance maladie est un souci partagé
par tous la santé est lié à l'emploi
si vous n'avez pas de travail on n'avait
pas d'assurance les fonds sont tellement
cher qu'une petite maladie peut
complètement détruire une famille
financièrement
et pourtant pas loin du centre ville
dans un quartier pauvre un centre
médical financé par l'état
450 personnes viennent s'y faire soigner
gratuitement chaque semaine tout ou
presque
nantes aucune ressource le docteur adams
pédiatre a choisi d'aider les plus
démunis des gens qui ne peuvent pas se
payer une assurance maladie pour
s'assurer dans le privé il faut sortir
beaucoup d'argent dans sa poche pour une
famille de trois personnes
ça coûte environ 450 dollars par mois
parmi les patients beaucoup d'afro
américains est de plus en plus
d'hispaniques des mexicains qui ne parle
pas un mot d'anglais des traducteurs
payé par le centre les aide dans leurs
démarches
en général ils ont très peu de
ressources
c'est très difficile pour eux de trouver
un emploi alors qu'il croyait au rêve
américain en venant dans ce pays
la famille de brindas vit sous le seuil
de pauvreté comme 30% des américains
elles bénéficient d'une prise en charge
totale de l'état
qu'avez vous payez rien rien du tout
pour mon fils et quant à moi comme je
reçois une allocation pour mes enfants
je paye un ou deux dollars pour les
médicaments
le pharmacien lui n'est pas content de
la réputation des etats unis se faire
soigner dans ce pays n'est selon lui pas
plus cher qu'ailleurs les gens sont
anxieux car ils pensent que les soins
médicaux sont chers
c'est une illusion mais il ya des
endroits comme celui ci en ville ou se
soigner ne revient pas cher
les gens sont anxieux tiens ne savent
pas que nous existons
aux etats unis près de la moitié de la
population n'a aucune assurance maladie
parmi eux une majorité est
afro-américain et d'hispaniques qui
supportent barack obama le
candidat démocrate a en effet promis une
grande réforme du système de santé
le dire